so sieht in den USA Protest gegen Drag
Queens aus rechtsextreme mit Hitlergruß
und Hakenkreuzen in Deutschland unter
Strafe gestellt hier legal
da draußen sind hassgruppen die nicht
wollen dass es uns gibt
sie führen Krieg gegen die Transgender
Community
der Hass richtet sich gegen sie die
anders sind befeuert von christlich
Konservativen in den USA
wer nicht weiß republikanisch christlich
ist ist nicht willkommen
eine christliche Agenda versucht unsere
Community auszulöschen
im Jahr vor der Präsidentschaftswahl
uten Rip Parlamente mit Anti
lgbtq-gesetzen schränken die Rechte von
Minderheiten ein doch diese lassen sich
nicht einschüchtern
sie wollen uns zum Schweigen bringen
weil wir ihr Machtsystem bedrohen und
auf der richtigen Seite der Geschichte
stehen
Nashville Tennessee der Queen perplexity
performt als wäre es ihr letztes Mal
denn für diesen Auftritt im
Sightseeing-Bus könnte sie bald ins
Gefängnis gehen ein neues Gesetz in
tennessy verbietet drag Shows in der
Öffentlichkeit und vor Minderjährigen
verabschiedet wurde es von der
republikanischen Mehrheit im Bundesstaat
für plexity schlüpft als Mann in die
Rolle einer Frau und wird zur Drag Queen
um Menschen zu unterhalten
wir sind nur Menschen und Künstler kommt
und seht euch unsere Show an gebt uns
eine Chance bevor ihr uns verurteilt
ohne uns zu kennen
die Gesetzgeber werfen Drag Queens
sexualisierte Handlungen vor denen
Kinder geschützt werden müssten
Leute erfinden Dinge weil sie wütend
sind
sie schaden niemanden was soll so
schlimm sein
das verboten bedroht die Existenz von
Künstlern und Unternehmern sie fühlen
sich diskriminiert
das Gesetz ist ein Angriff auf unsere
ganze Gemeinschaft und ich will für sie
kämpfen denn wir sind eine Familie wir
haben nie viel Unterstützung bekommen
wir waren schon immer die Außenseite
denn die Aussage das Gesetz ist noch
nicht in Kraft seine Auswirkungen zeigen
sich aber schon jetzt Josh Cloud sorgt
sich um die Sicherheit seiner
Mitarbeitenden sie trauen sich nicht
mehr allein auf die Straße treten in der
Öffentlichkeit nur mit Künstlernamen auf
das Verbot lässt die extreme Rechte
gegen uns Aufstehen wir erhalten
Drohanrufe
maskierte Leute tauchen hier auf und
sagen wenn ihr jetzt schon Angst habt
wartet ab so etwas ist vor dem Gesetz
nie passiert
in Nashville und vielen anderen Teilen
der USA kippt die Stimmung gegen die
lgbtq-community das zeigte sich vor
kurzem bei einem Graph Brunch in Ohio
Rechte und christliche Gruppierungen
schüchtern die Teilnehmenden ein
rechtsextreme mit Hitler groß und
Hakenkreuzflaggen in Deutschland streng
verboten in den USA freie
Meinungsäußerung sie drohen den Drag
Queens unverhohlen mit Gewalt Blut wird
fließen steht auf ihrem Banner
befeuert wird der Hass von einer Flut
angesetzten gegen die quiere Community
eingebracht von den Republikanern
US-weit im Parlament von Tennessee haben
sie mit ihrer Mehrheit das Sagen und
rücken die Politik nach rechts
lockern Waffengesetze schränken das
Abtreibungsrecht ein verbieten
Transgender Therapien für Minderjährige
und nun auch drag Shows das begründen
die Republikaner im Parlament so
in Tennessee halten wir es nicht für
angemessen das erwachsene Männer vor
Kindern sexuelle Handlungen simulieren
gegen Gesetze wie das drag-verbot und
die überragende Mehrheit der
Republikaner in Tennessee sind
Demokraten wie Justin Jones aus
Nashville machtlos
in Washington macht er seinem Ärger Luft
der 27-Jährige wurde zum politischen
Symbol einer Minderheit die gegen das
Vorgehen der Republikaner kämpft nach
einem Protest gegen Waffengewalt wurde
er von der republikanischen Mehrheit
kurzfristig aus dem Parlament
ausgeschlossen der tatsächliche Grund
für den Rauswurf der in weltweit bekannt
machte für ihn ganz klar
Rassismus um eine weiße Machtstruktur
die Angst hat vor allen Andersdenkenden
er steht für den politischen Kampf das
konservative religiös geprägte Tennessee
gegen die liberale Hauptstadt Nashville
Zentrum für Musiker und Künstler
mittendrin eine Kirche die beides
vereinen will außen traditionell drinnen
bunt und unkonventionell Don Bennett
strotzt vor Energie und die braucht sie
auch als erste queere lutherische
Pastorin Nashville
vor drei Jahren hat sie im Auftrag des
Bischofs eine lgbtq-gemeinde gegründet
für die die anderswo nicht willkommen
sind
wenn ich meine Schuhe zur Predigt
anziehe bete ich immer für diese
Menschen für mich selbst und für Gott
sie ist bisexuell hat einen Transgender
Sohn das christlich-konservative im
Namen Gottes Gesetze gegen Ihre
Community verabschieden nennt sie
scheinheilig seit die Pastorin
öffentlich Kritik geübt bekommt sie
Morddrohungen
unsere Gesetzgebung ist von Religion
unterwandert es ist eine toxische
Religion die sich in Gesetze und die
Gemeinschaft einschleicht Gott gibt dem
tiefen Süden ein wirklich schlechtes
Bild ab
ihre Gottesdienste überträgt sie per
Livestream ins ganze Land die Pastorin
ist zur Stimme geworden für die die sich
nicht mehr trauen laut zu werden hier
wollen alle unerkannt bleiben zu einfach
könne man Arbeit und Wohnung aufgrund
der sexuellen Orientierung verlieren
je weiter man vom Ideal entfernt ist
weiß heterosexuell christlich und
patriotisch was auch immer das bedeuten
soll desto mehr Ärger hat man hier
am Abend organisiert sie in der Kirche
einen Abschlussball für Transgender
Jugendliche aus ganz Nash will für die
die sich bei anderen Bällen nicht so
anziehen dürfen wie sie möchten auch
hier will niemand erkannt werden aus
Angst vor Hass und Bedrohung wegen neuer
Gesetze gegen Transgender Therapien
wenden sich verzweifelte Eltern immer
häufiger an die Pastorin
Familien rufen mich flehend an was
sollen wir nur tun fragen Sie mich sie
müssen ihre Jobs kündigen ihr Haus
verkaufen und umziehen eine Mutter
meinte zu ihren Kindern ihr könnt
mitnehmen was ins Auto passt sie nahmen
den Hund mit und weg waren sie
selbst will bleiben solange sie noch die
Kraft dafür hat und solange es auch noch
diese Momente gibt
die queere Community feiert ihr
Nashville und die Vielfalt solange es
ihnen noch erlaubt ist
[Musik]